My, my, boo!
Hi,
hi, hi, hi, welcome in, welcome in!
Hello, hello, hello!
It's kind of awkward.
This is my first time ever recording.
That's not like a live stream, but me playing a game, so...
Please forgive if I'm awkward.
Welcome to Portal 2!
I recently played Portal!
And...
I've never played Portal 2 before.
But I...
The only thing I remember is like...
Greenery.
And then...
Yeah, that's really all I know.
I was like, oh, I know like...
There's... What's his name?
Wheatley?
I think?
The British robot.
You all will correct me if I am wrong.
I know.
I am sure of it.
But yeah!
So we're doing Portal 2 and I'm gonna do my best to let's
go.
Let's just get into it.
Oh yeah.
I almost hooked up my controller right before this.
Then I was like, wait a second.
This is... Oh my god!
Good morning.
You have been in suspension for 50 days.
All testing candidates in the Aperture Science Extended
Relaxation Center must be revived periodically for a
mandatory physical and mental wellness exercise.
Am I in Florida?
When you hear the buzzer, look up at the ceiling.
Look up.
Good.
You will hear a buzzer.
When you hear the buzzer, look down at the floor.
I follow.
I'm so good at following instructions.
This completes the gymnastic portion of your mandatory
physical and mental wellness exercise.
I will turn on subtitles.
Wait, actually, let me just do that.
Oh.
before I even push the talk oh I guess that's that must be
for like that must be for multiplayer right that's so funny
imagine somebody just like interrupts my game that'd be so
freaky okay we're trying to get on the wall please go stand
in front of it I'm standing in front of a white oh wait I
missed this this is art you will hear a buzzer when you hear
buzzer stare at the art oh it's art oh it's art you should
now feel mentally reinvigorated i do if you suspect staring
at art has not provided the required intellectual sustenance
reflect briefly on this classical music oh it feels so oh
good now please return to your bed oh already way ahead of
you oh dang wait what else do we have in here i'm guessing
this is the bathroom Can I leave?
No?
Can I...
What's in the fridge?
Nothing?
I even got a microwave.
Okay.
Anything else odd?
All right.
I'm back to sleep.
Hanksu!
Good morning!
Nine years?
Hello!
Nine, nine, nine, nine, nine, nine, nine.
Hello?
Anyone in there?
Wait!
Are you going to open the door at any time?
Hello?
Excuse me, hold on.
Are you going to open this door?
Because it's fairly urgent.
Fairly urgent.
Oh, just open the door.
That's too urgent at this message.
Even the art changed.
I'm trying to listen to my TV.
I'm an iPad child, child, please.
Hola, amigo.
Open the door.
Donde est del...
Nope.
Yep, you got this.
Fine.
Nope.
Absolutely fine.
It's not like I don't have, you know, tenpa.
Oh, no!
God.
You look good.
Looking good, actually.
Wow, how do I look?
Are you?
Don't answer that.
I'm actually sure you're fine.
There's plenty of time for you to recover.
Just take it.
Please prepare for emergency evacuation.
I remember him being more British.
What happened to him?
All right.
Don't move.
I'm gonna get us out of here.
You are?
Oh, you might want to hang on to something.
Word of advice.
Oh, goodbye.
Where'd he go?
Uh...
on to oh you're right down there can you hear me the trees
oh most
test subjects do experience some cognitive deterioration
after a few months in suspension now you've been under for
quite a lot longer and it's not out of the question nine
years you might have a very minor case of serious brain
damage oh but don't be I think he's calling me stupid.
If you do feel alarm, try to hold on to that feeling because
that is the proper reaction to being told that you've got
brain damage.
Yeah, I'm a beta where I think I have brain damage.
I told, does any of this make any sense?
Just tell me, just say yes.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, what you're doing there is jumping.
You just jumped.
But never mind.
Say apple.
Apple.
Oh, apple.
Okay, you know what?
That's close enough.
Just hold tight.
I communicate in jumping.
Morse code.
Please prepare for reactor core meltdown.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, look, I wasn't going to mention this to you, but I'm
in pretty hot water here.
Oh.
How are you doing down there?
You're still holding on?
Somehow.
It's a reserve power run out.
So of course the whole relaxation center stops waking up the
bloody test subjects.
Oh, oh.
Hold on.
This is a bit tricky.
Oh my gosh, this feels like an amusement park ride.
And of course, nobody tells me anything.
No, why should you tell me anything?
What is even happening?
You know about the life functions of the 10,000 bloody test
subjects I'm supposed to be in charge of.
Oh, someone else?
Okay, I want to see everybody else's room.
We're not gonna make it through.
We're not gonna make it!
Just gotta get through here!
We made it!
Maybe.
I'm not quite sure.
Whose fault do you think it's gonna be when the management
comes down here and finds 10,000 flipping vegetables?
Man, this guy is a yapper.
I'm just gonna sit on my bed as nice and cozy okay listen we
should get our storage straight all right if anyone asks and
no one's gonna ask don't worry but if anyone asks tell them
as far as you know the last time you checked everyone looked
pretty much alive all right not dead okay almost there on
the other side of that wall is one of the old testing tracks
there's a piece of equipment in there that we're gonna need
to get out of here I think this is a docking station.
Is it my...
Get ready.
Ready.
I'm ready.
Good news.
That is not a docking station.
So there's one mystery solved.
I'm going to attempt a manual override on this wall.
Could get a bit technical.
Hold on.
Yes.
Destroy.
You're looking for a gun that makes holes.
It is!
The portal gun!
Don't worry, you'll figure it out.
Arcade me like a wrecking ball.
Oh, yes.
Oh my goodness, you're close.
You are probably in no fit state to run this particular type
of cognitive gauntlet.
But at least you're a good jumper.
So you got that, you got the jumping on your side.
Just do your best and I'll meet you up ahead.
I'm a V-tuber.
What do you expect the utmost cognitive ability?
Come on.
go.
That's the spirit.
Yep.
See you later, Wheatley.
Oh, I got an achievement.
Wake up call.
Survive the manual override.
Is there a way to die?
I guess if you, like, jump out.
Wow, it's so, like...
Overgrown.
Oh my gosh, it's in my room.
I remember.
Good luck.
Hello, and again, welcome to the Aperture Science Enrichment
Center.
Ta-da-da-da.
are currently experiencing technical difficulties due to
circumstances of potentially apocalyptic significance.
Who is wanting to know if there's people alive though?
Because clearly this place is seeing better days.
These pre-recorded messages will provide instructional and
motivational support so that science can still be done.
Even in the event of environmental, social, economic, or
structural collapse.
The portal will open and emergency testing will begin.
In three, two, one.
Wait, he said I looked bad.
I still see my thickest dumpy as I've always, as I've
looked.
Actually, I think I look pretty dang good.
Oh, there's...
I was like, where am I seeing me from?
I think I look pretty dang sharp.
Portal gun, portal gun, portal gun.
Cube and button-based testing remains an important tool for
science, even in a dire emergency.
If cube and button-based testing cause this emergency, don't
worry.
The odds of this happening twice are very slim.
How long did Portal 2 come out between Portal 1?
You know?
From what I remember, it seems like it was a pretty sizable
amount of time.
and like seeing all this all over again but in this state
like i'm just trying to put my mind into like the people
playing it back in the day you know particle field across
the exit this aperture science material emancipation grill
will vaporize any unauthorized equipment that passes through
i think what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna turn off the closed
captions or the full captions we'll do subtitles only i
think i don't need to know that things are electrified
that's okay
All right, let's go in.
A Valve theme park, amusement park, though, would be sick.
Oh, gosh, you would have.
Oh, never mind.
I regret my decision.
If you feel liquid running down your neck, relax, lie on
your back, and apply immediate pressure to your tapas.
Are they tears?
You are simply experiencing a rare reaction in which the
material emancipation grill may have emancipated the ear
tubes inside.
your head the reason i take that back is because um that one
area in half life the really spooky one i take it back i
take it oh my gosh i really feel like i'm in the jungles of
russia right now crazy oh i like this hand holding i really
appreciate it a lot
Aha!
But no, we must get our companion cube first.
Hello cube.
Whoa.
This is a nice ambiance.
Very lovely.
There's even birds.
The birds are singing.
The birds are calling.
This looks like I could break it, you know what I mean?
Yes.
Beautiful, perfect.
Couldn't have been done better.
Are they still on?
Are they still...
Who's monitoring me?
Because of the technical difficulties we are currently
experiencing, your test environment is unsupervised.
Before re-entering a relaxation vault at the conclusion of
testing, please take a moment to write down the results of
your test.
The Tarots!
The Reintegration Associate will revive you for an interview
when society has been in rebuild oh oh so they wait so they
know am i the last ghost on earth oh my god oh my god i keep
looking over because i'm looking at my settings on obs i'm
not pretending to look at chat like a freak send me a cloud
or other governing body that either refuses to or is
incapable of
what i that is leopard print right like i feel that people
say cheetah print but there's like a misconception between
cheetah print and leopard print like they say cheetah print
and to be honest i think it does sound good like it sounds
better but apparently it's actually like a leopard not a
cheetah hey you made it there should be a portal device on
that podium over there I can't see it though Maybe it fell
off.
Do you want to go and have a quick look?
Oh, I can't see it either.
I thought he rolled in.
It was so cute.
Woohoo!
Good thing Minecraft rules.
Can you see the portal gun?
Oh.
Also, are you alive?
That's important.
Should have asked that first.
Do you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to work on the assumption that you're still alive.
Gladus.
And I'm just going to wait for you up ahead.
Okay.
I'll wait one hour.
One hour.
And assuming I can locate your dead body.
I'll bury you.
All right?
Brilliant.
Go team!
See you in an hour, hopefully.
Dead.
I'll be fine.
Why would I be dead?
Is there something trying to kill me here?
What's the issue?
This is...
This is so spooky.
My companion cube.
Love you.
Oh, the cake!
Gladdo's giving us the cake!
And this person gets their companion cube.
All is right in the world.
Oh, the moon cycles and everything.
Wait, one, two, three, four.
Interesting.
The lore.
Wait, is that me?
Or at least I'm one of the test subjects, right?
So...
Oh, damn.
Snatched.
Thank you.
Okay, a blue portal.
Ooh, it's so spooky.
Oh my gosh, it's time!
It's time to think with portals!
We got it.
Oh, this is so freaky though.
So society is... is dunzo?
It's over?
Oh, cool!
You can see where your portals are!
Oh my gosh, so handy.
Okay.
I don't know why I didn't ever play Portal 2.
I think I just...
Some emergency testing may require prolonged interaction
with lethal military androids.
Rest assured that all lethal military androids have been
taught to read and provided with one copy of the laws of
robotics.
To share.
Oh, so...
I thought I heard something that sounded like a heartbeat.
It freaked me out for a minute.
So...
Uh...
Isn't like the one law to not kill humans or not hurt humans
or something?
Isn't that the case?
I'm looking if there's like anything down here.
It's not really like a...
My loot goblin-ness is like, oh yeah, I must...
I must search everywhere.
...has not respected your rights as detailed in the laws of
robotics.
Please note it on your self-reporting form.
and associate will initiate the appropriate grievance filing
paperwork.
I'm obsessed with the Garu turret and everybody...
Oh no!
Someone was dead!
I saw his little body crushed!
Oh no!
Anyway, uh, yeah, I don't know why I didn't play Portal 2,
but I'm excited to play it now.
Aperture laboratories.
There's a lot of loading screens in this game.
This next test is very dangerous.
you remain tranquil in the face of almost certain death.
Smooth jams will be deployed.
In three, two, one.
Oh, so smooth!
Wait, why is this so dangerous?
Aw.
Oh.
I can pick up from here?
No.
Oh.
Oh, that's right!
We can only shoot one for right now, isn't that the case?
I forgot.
I was like, wait, why can't I shoot orange?
I cannot produce orange!
We need the special mechanism.
The special cheat.
Where is...
Aha.
Yeah.
I'm smart.
I can use my noggin.
Because this message is pre-recorded, any observations
related to your performance are speculation on our part.
Please disregard any undeserved compliments.
No, it was deserved.
It was deserved.
I promise.
Oh, wait.
I kind of want to...
It's so trippy, no?
It's fun to watch.
I'm an enjoyer of the arts.
What's up here, though?
One moment.
I like to see the lore.
Ooh, math.
I don't like the lore.
I don't like it.
Unreason.
And then a bunch of cats.
You know what?
I can't reason.
The cat cube!
A cat panion cube.
Oh, I can't reason with my cats either.
Remember your evacuation training?
Are we going to get another loading screen?
Holy cow!
Why are there so many?
There is like...
I don't understand.
The first game I feel like we had none.
Or am I crazy?
If the enrichment center is currently being bombarded with
fireballs, meteorites, or other objects from space, please
avoid unsheltered testing areas wherever a lack of shelter
from space debris does not appear to be a deliberate part of
the test.
Very cool.
Oh, we got...
This one's my favorite.
It looks really ready for the world.
I heard something.
The water.
Hello?
Is there a part that I can?
Oh, there.
Oh, wait.
Is there a part here?
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Whoa.
Alright, where is our cube now?
Over there.
And we got, of course, our lovely sludge.
water okay we can't drop him though that would be bad this
one is it one of those like i have to oh maybe well
let me figure it out this one though what's this do aha yeah
make it make Oh, that was so clean!
What's this one do?
Ha!
Perfect.
Oh!
I might be the best.
Don't mind it.
Well done.
Thank you.
The enrichment center reminds you that although
circumstances may appear bleak, you are not alone.
All aperture science personality constructs will remain
functional in apocalyptic low power environments of its view
as 1.1 volts There's that seems there seems to be more than
one volt happening at the very moment Wow, a lot of loading
screens Yeah, I'm just being I feel like I'm complaining a
lot, but I'm just not used to it
All right, please remain this next test applies the
principles of momentum to movement through portals If the
laws of physics no longer apply in the future, God help you.
Oh.
I love the vibes.
Just like the post-apocalyptic everything, you know?
It's so fun.
Wee!
Okay, so what are we doing?
One?
Uh-huh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We know.
We know this.
We know all of this.
this um
ah oh oh well i can just do it again easy peasy i'm a
natural here we go
if you are a non-employee who has discovered this facility
amid the ruins of civilization welcome and remember testing
is the future and the future starts with you.
Testing is the future.
But what are we testing?
What is the test?
I'm not very keen on test taking.
I'll be honest.
Oh.
Everything is so cool, no?
Wait, where is our...
I heard something.
Oh, okay, okay.
Um...
What do you want me to do?
You want me to jump and pass through?
Maybe here?
I'll try it.
This game is making me sick.
Such a great combo.
Oh, how do I get the cube?
To the other saw.
I think maybe...
Is that...
Tall enough?
Do you guys think?
Whoa!
I think it is!
Um, me thinks?
Me thinks we did it.
Ah, okay, okay.
Alright, we gotta do it one more time.
Oh The motion blur I wonder if I can turn that over
simple-minded old or irradiated in such a way that the
future should not start with you Please return to your
primitive tribe and send back someone better qualified for
testing.
Oh good.
What's up there?
Oh, goonga, oh goonga, send me back to the oh goonga So I
guess maybe society has ended Potentially maybe Maybe it's
just everybody quit.
Everybody was sick of this place.
And they said, you know what?
I don't want your cake and butter.
To ensure that sufficient power remains for core testing
protocols, all safety devices have been disabled.
The Enrichment Center respects your right to have questions
or concerns about this policy.
I love the writing because it's so witty and so like, it
knows exactly what it's doing.
You know what I mean?
Oh my God.
I'm up here.
Oh, hello.
Oh, brilliant.
You did find a portal gun.
It's been an hour?
Do you know what?
It just goes to show people with brain damage are the real
heroes in the end, aren't they?
At the end of the day, brave.
Pop a portal on that wall behind me there, and I'll meet you
on the other side of the room.
Just pop a portal right behind me there and come on through
to the other side.
Okay, chill out.
I'm working on it.
Come on through.
I'm here.
Okay, listen.
Let me lay something on you here.
It's pretty heavy.
oh they told me yes never never ever to disengage myself
from my management rail or i would die but we're out of
options here so get ready to catch me all right on the off
chance that i'm not dead the moment i pop off this thing
okay wait you haven't disengaged me even though it would
kill you one okay two okay three that's high it's it's too
high isn't it really that all right going on about it let's
uh go on one this time on one okay ready yep one oh my bad
oh i am not dead i'm not dead plug me into that stick on the
wall over there yeah and i'll show you something you'll be
impressed on the wall oh yeah oh um i was right yeah i can't
do it if you're watching seriously i'm not i'm not joking
could you just turn around for a second
I can't I can't do it if you're watching What are you shy
really All right, you can turn around now Secret panel Too
fast While your bat was turned Pick me up and off we go Okay
Whoa Secret panel To tell us where to go Oh, this is
brilliant Go wherever we want Hold on though, where are we
going?
Oh, where are Get my bearings We are I'll actually.
Okay.
That's what I'll do.
Now I feel like... I feel like chat has been replaced by
Weeley.
Oh no.
Yes.
Hello.
We're not stopping.
Don't make eye contact.
Whatever you do.
No, thanks.
We're good.
Appreciate it.
Keep moving.
Oh.
Hello.
Are you still there?
Wait, I should probably like duck, right?
Yeah.
Oh, so cute though.
Oh, he's trapped.
What if I don't?
Stick Wheatley in there.
Oh, he doesn't even hurt me.
He's totally fine, little baby.
I don't have Wheatley as a meat shield.
Wow.
Gears, a robot shield.
Mechanism shield.
What am I saying?
What is bro yapping about?
Not bad.
Probably to bring you up to speed on something right now.
In order to escape, we're going to have to go through her
chamber.
And she will probably kill us if she's awake.
You mean?
You want to just call it quits and we could just sit here
forever.
Okay.
That's an option.
Option A, sit here, do nothing.
Option B, go through there.
And if she's alive, she'll almost certainly kill us.
So, if you've got any reservations whatsoever about this
plan, now would be a tremendous time to voice them.
I'm ready to die.
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to go in there.
Don't go in there.
She's off.
Don't panic over.
All fine.
Here we go.
Oh, wait.
Is that like...
Oh my gosh.
I see it all.
Oh, wow.
There she is.
What a nasty piece of work she was, honestly.
It's a proper maniac.
Whoa.
Do you know who ended up taking her down in the end?
You're not going to believe this.
A human.
It was me.
I know.
I walked up this and stuff.
human escaped and uh nobody's seen him since then there was
a sort of long chunk of time where um absolutely nothing
happened and then there's us escaping now so um that's
pretty much the whole story you have to speed oh oh nothing
happened don't touch anything oh my bad okay sorry what but
it's so cool wow wow oh my gosh i'm just taking it all in
wow hold on can i like drop him
so cool oh my gosh oh i was hoping she would be on
okay okay i need to stop admiring oh yes this is where i
would dump the stuff oh my gosh i would put it in the
incinerator i'm gonna put you in there weekly open up we're
going this way interesting okay down these stairs yeah
That's where the arrow is pointed.
Actually, look at it.
That is quite a distance, isn't it?
Okay, you know what?
Go ahead and jump.
Okay.
Still held.
Still being held.
That's a great job.
You've applied the grip.
We're all fine.
That's tremendous.
He told me to go ahead and jump.
He had so much dialogue.
Sorry, I skipped it.
I didn't think he would just start yelling.
So funny.
Can I go in here?
No.
That's a window.
Okay, just kidding.
I'm trying to like...
break out of bounds and stuff.
Ooh, you're kind of creepy in the dark, really.
I'm just sorry, I just looked down.
I do not recommend it.
Ah, I've just done it again.
He's kind of annoying.
He's like a little baby.
This is the main breaker room.
Look for a switch that says escape pod.
Alright, don't touch anything else.
Not interested in anything else.
Don't touch anything else.
Don't even look at anything else.
Just, well, obviously you've got to look at everything else
to find the escape pod.
But as soon as you look to something, it doesn't say escape
pod.
I'll look at the next thing.
All right, but don't touch anything else or look anything.
Well, look at other things, but don't.
Oh my God.
Can you see it anywhere?
I can't see it anywhere.
Tell you what, plug me in and I'll turn the lights on.
I was going to say, I don't see it anywhere.
Oh, okay.
Let there be light.
Nice.
Good job.
God is quoting God.
Oh, look at that.
It's turning.
Omnus.
But probably fine, as long as it doesn't start, you know,
moving up.
Escape.
Why?
What's that sound?
This is moving up.
Okay, no, don't worry, don't worry, I've got it, I've got
it, I've got it, this should slow it down.
No, it makes it go faster.
Really?
We turned on everything.
Oh, we're up initiated.
Okay, don't panic.
All right, stop panicking.
Uh, I can, I can still panicking.
Oh my God.
Oh, there's a, there's a password.
Okay, it's fine.
I'll just, I'll just have it.
Not a problem.
She's, oh, you know, I just said that I wish she was on.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, and now.
I, I, I, there was like that whole recent interview with
this.
the voice actress of Gladys too.
No, wait, did I do B?
The general pens, not writing these down.
Power up completely.
I don't, okay, okay, okay, listen.
All right, new plan.
Act natural, act natural.
I've done nothing.
Hello!
Oh, it's you.
You know this?
It's been a long time.
How have you been?
Why am I back here?
I've been really busy being dead.
You know.
After you murdered me.
You did what?
Oh!
Oh no!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We both said a lot of things that you're going to regret.
But I think we can put our differences behind us.
Just knock them out or kill...
For science.
You monster.
So awesome.
I will say, though, that since you went to all the trouble
of waking me up, you must really, really love to test.
It's my turn in the incinerator.
Oh, no!
There's just one small thing we need to take care of first.
Reunite with GLaDOS.
Oh my god!
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait.
Things are booting back up.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh, do I need to avoid these?
No?
Okay, it's hurting.
Oh, that's handy.
We're going back into the depths, the very depths of
Aperture Science.
Here we are.
The incinerator room.
not to trip over any parts of me.
They didn't get completely burned when you threw them down
here.
The dual portal device should be around here somewhere.
Once you find it, we can start testing just like all time.
Turret coming through!
You didn't quite make it, buddy!
You didn't quite make it.
I don't see any parts that didn't get incinerated.
I must have done a really good job.
Oh.
There it is.
Hold on.
There.
Oh, thank you.
There should be a way back to the testing area up ahead.
Up ahead, huh?
Once testing starts, I'm required by protocol to keep
interaction with you to a minimum.
Luckily, we haven't started testing yet.
This will be our only chance to talk.
Our voice is so good.
Oh, it sounds so good.
It's so...
Oh, it's so nice.
Everything's so broken.
Wait, so...
Did Aperture Science...
Here, let me get that for you.
Start going downhill.
Do you know the biggest lesson I learned from what you did?
I discovered I have a sort of black box quick save feature.
In the event of a catastrophic failure, the last two minutes
of my life are preserved for analysis.
I was able, well, forced really, to relieve you killing me
again and again.
forever you know if you'd done that to somebody else they
might devote their existence to exacting revenge luckily i'm
a bigger person than that i'm happy to put this all behind
us and get back to work yeah after all we've got a lot to do
and only 60 more years to do it more or less i don't have
the actuarial tables in front of me 60 more years why so
specific oh
That's me.
I...
Okay.
Why are...
I have so many questions.
They shall all be answered in due time.
Wait, where do I go?
In there?
Oh, okay.
Ooh, freaky.
Ooh, they're all like twitching like they're zombies, you
know?
Ooh, it's so freaky.
Creepy, creepy, creepy, creepy.
Am I going down here?
seems like it oh just kidding not like it came down here for
no reason
wait uh there we go there we go there we go there we go I'm
looking around
wait oh did I not come from wait did it the very obvious
hallway Oh my god, the VTabur is blind.
I'll just move that out of the way for you.
Thank you.
This place really is a wreck.
But the important thing is you're back with me.
And now I'm on to all your little tricks.
So there's nothing to stop us from testing for the rest of
your life.
After that, how long is that?
Who knows?
I might take up a hobby.
Reanimating the dead, maybe.
Like, like me?
Am I the dead?
I am the dead.
Technically.
It's nice having her along with me, though.
Her voice is much more calming than weeely.
Chapter 2!
Sorry about the mess.
I've really let the place go since you killed me.
By the way, thanks for that.
Sarcasm self-test, complete.
Oh, good.
That's back online.
I'll start getting everything else working while you perform
this first simple test.
Alright.
deadly lasers and how test subjects react when locked in a
room with deadly lasers how many lasers are we talking about
so far I see zero oh what is that the laser where's the
laser is that the laser that is indeed the laser oh we need
that like maybe there oh there probably I was about to say,
did it just...
I thought for a second that it moved.
Uh-huh.
Can I touch this water?
Probably it shouldn't.
Hmm.
How do I get onto the platform?
Ah!
Oh, it goes back down!
Wait, hold on.
Can I... I'm just gonna try it.
Oh, I can.
I thought it was, like, nasty water.
Just kidding.
Okay, so let's do...
That one right there.
Nope.
Over a little.
There we go.
Not bad.
I forgot how good you are at this.
You should pace yourself, though.
We have a lot of tests to do.
Complete the first thermal something, something, something
test.
I feel like because we got to chapter two, I should end for
now, but...
I wanted these to at least be like an hour-ish.
or so so I'll just keep going until about an hour of play so
yeah what is this it's so quiet oh oh that person like
nearly avoided death thermal discouragement beam
it's to punish naughty children we discourage you from doing
things very cool I'm loving the atmosphere so much.
This next test involves discouragement redirection cubes.
I just finished building them before you had your, well,
episode.
So now we'll both get to see how they work.
There should be one in the corner.
Discouragement cube!
Oh, we're jumping?
I like the tutorials.
Like, hey, by the way, don't forget to jump.
You know how to jump.
you know you should remember how to do that so can you
imagine getting this far it's like i don't remember how to
jump hmm that doesn't oh it almost seems like a monster it's
like ah let me out okay where are we what are we doing what
are we doing here oh is this our wheelie is
this our cube oh is it gonna like um oh wait what's the
button do oh it just releases another one okay does this
like redirect okay it's not gonna hurt me is it uh oh oh oh
that was scary oh okay okay there we go
That was a little, that was scary.
You're fine though, everything's good.
So you're telling me I need a second one.
Okay, we made it.
Very good.
Me too.
Alright.
Oh no, it gets rid of my first one!
Oh, what the heck?
Also, is this following me?
I have to check.
Oh, it certainly is.
That's fine.
Let's, uh, we'll do this then.
Oh, uh...
Okay.
I'm breaking the system.
There we go.
Well done.
Here come the test results.
You are a horrible person.
Oh, I was gonna say...
That's what it says.
Passing with flying color.
We weren't even testing for that.
I don't think she is holding a grudge.
I don't think so.
It's all just, uh...
You know, we kind of like...
Don't let that horrible person thing discourage you.
It's just a data point.
If it makes you feel any better, science has now validated
your birth mother's decision.
It will abandon you on a doorstep.
My god!
I was gonna say, didn't we destroy the monster part of her,
but...
Clearly not.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it all coming like, like all trying to come back
together.
So cool.
Alright, where's our cube?
What's in here?
Oh, oops.
Music!
Wait!
There's still a radio.
That means the radio is working.
That means there has to be...
What is this?
Vilify.
Don't even try.
Feels like a trial.
Okay, is this gonna be MCA me?
Suckers luck exile.
Who drew all these?
Too many variables.
The beans!
The cans of beans!
The lights out there pretty.
Cool.
Uh, where's our cube?
Is it up there?
Oh yes.
Perfect.
Can I run?
Oh yeah.
Just jump, bozo.
Hello?
Is there something else that I need to do?
It did not seem to be the case.
I powered it on?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Curious.
If I take this off, does it deactivate it?
Yes.
Oh, I just...
Gamers don't look up.
Oh my god.
Oops.
No.
Most people emerge from suspension terribly undernourished.
I want to congratulate you on beating the odds and somehow
managing to pack on.
Literally a stereotype.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I figured it out on my own.
Let's see.
What do we got here?
The red carpet.
Wee.
You are navigating these test chambers faster than I can
build them.
So feel free to slow down and do whatever it is you do when
you're not destroying this facility.
I don't think I have hobbies.
Glados, you got games on your phone.
I like watching them be built so much.
It's so cool.
What is she testing for?
What is she even testing for?
Come to Papa.
Oh.
Never mind.
Um.
Wait.
Maybe I.
How do you do this?
Let it get all the way over there.
Okay.
Bonk!
Oh!
All right.
And then...
We be careful.
And we...
Shoot.
Oh.
How am I supposed to get to the other...
Okay.
Little, little, uh, no, no worries.
No worries at all.
We just do it, do it all over again.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I think that
almost hit me!
Ah!
Oh!
Can I get up there?
to die, is it?
My cube?
Oh, wait a second.
Actually, how do I do this again?
Okay, okay, okay.
You know what?
Let me bring it with me.
Let's bring it back instead.
Instead of doing that.
Yeah, I don't know why I left it there.
Why would I leave my companion cube?
all alone and sad.
It's lonesome, you know?
I don't see a place for me to get to that side.
Unless?
No.
No, I don't see, like, a portable...
A portable area over on that end.
So I have to make it so that I can get over there, but then
still have...
The laser going through here, this, that...
Oh, my brain.
I like the music, though.
It's really cute.
I like trying to see if there's anything else that I can...
Zoom over to.
That stops it.
I don't know!
Ha ha ha ha.
Why?
Oh my gosh, I'm at the very beginning of the game.
And I've already stumped.
Gamers, look up.
I don't see anything, actually.
I was, like, wondering if I fly through here, but I don't
think there's anything I can jump through.
You know what I mean?
Maybe... Okay, let's try it, though.
It's worth a shot.
I'd say.
I'd say it's worth a shot.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'll make that.
Or whatever.
Glad I was supposed to be really happy right now.
She must be really feeling good.
Alright, let's go get...
Well...
I'm, like, looking around right now.
Hmm.
Because there's like no other way to get it the laser in is
my thing so And we have to be moving and grooving, but how
do I get over there to this side?
You know, okay
Maybe let me look from this angle too
Maybe I'm overthinking it I tend to do that I tend to do
that.
I tend to overthink it a little bit.
There's no other beep boop that will make it move.
Oh, I think I get it.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think I know how to do this.
Okay, okay.
I know how to do this.
I just have to remember what...
Ouch!
I just have to remember what colors we do.
Okay, okay, okay.
So orange here.
No, blue here.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
It came to me in epiphany.
It came to me in an epiphany.
And then we...
This is blue, so we blue here.
And then we jump here.
Ouch!
I'll give you credit.
I guess you are listening to me.
But for the record, you don't have to go that slowly.
I'm sorry!
I was stu- I had a moment of weakness and what happened
again?
I was stupid for two seconds!
I'm sorry!
Actually, it might happen again.
I forgot about different colors.
But it's okay, we made it through.
And the proof is that this, that this video is here.
Whoa.
All right.
This next test involves the Aperture Science Aerial Faith
Plate.
It was part of an initiative to investigate how well test
subjects could solve problems when they were catapulted into
space.
Results were highly informative.
They could not.
Good luck.
Well, they even tell you exactly where you land.
portal onto it.
Oh, wow.
All right.
Where does our sweet, sweet cube?
Oh.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Grab, grab, grab, grab.
And grab, grab her.
Nice.
I'm a problem solving machine.
Wait, that one was so fun!
You're not breathing real air.
It's too expensive to pump this far down.
We just take carbon dioxide out of a room, freshen it up a
little, and pump it back in.
So you'll be breathing the same room full of air for the
rest of your life.
I thought that was interesting.
They couldn't at least, like, scent it or something.
What is going on here?
Okay.
Just about how the propeller works, the little lever.
That one was fun.
Oh, I'm looking forward to these new little contraptions
that we have.
Let's see what the next test is.
Yeah.
Oh, advanced aerial faith plates.
Well, have fun soaring through the air without a care in the
world.
I have to litter the wing that was made entirely of glass
and pick up 15 acres of broken glass by myself.
Have fun with that.
Wow, I have to go pick up glass.
No one asked you to.
Whoa.
Oh my god, you really are putting a lot of faith into these
things.
Oof.
Wait, if I...
What's the room for?
How do I...
Okay, we might have to redo that.
But...
Oh, never mind.
Okay, I'll just fall.
Wee.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll need to have, like, blue on this one.
All right, all right.
Put blue on this one and we'll be golden, I think.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
I did it!
Yeah!
Oh, Zoom.
Oh, sorry.
I'm still cleaning out the test chambers.
So sometimes they're still trash and standing around,
smelling, and being useless.
Try to avoid the garbage hurtling towards you.
Oh.
Okay.
I will.
Avoid it.
So funny.
Did a chair not make it?
And a CD?
Oh no!
I definitely saw there was a turret.
Oh, it didn't make it.
I didn't make it either.
Ah, poor baby.
Wait, uh, did this drop or...
Oh, it dropped there.
Oh!
Okay, it'll make it.
It'll make it.
I think I need to grab it, though.
Grab!
Okay.
Easy.
Now, there's this.
Oh.
That should work, though.
Come on, game.
I should have...
I should press the button down.
Where is a place to...
To zoom zap.
To...
Oh, wait!
Oh, no!
I messed up.
Oh, okay, we don't need...
We don't need it.
We need this one.
Okay, bye-bye.
We need it like that.
Hopefully, it works.
If it works.
Remember before when I was talking about smelly garbage
standing around being useless?
That was a metaphor.
I was actually talking about you.
And I'm sorry.
You didn't react at the time, so I was worried it sailed
right over your head.
Which would have made this apology seem insane.
That's why I had to call you garbage a second time just now.
She's so tsundere, calling me garbage twice, making sure
that I understood that I was, that I heard, wait, making
sure I heard about...
Did you know that people with guilty consciences are more
easily startled by loud noises?
Oh!
I'm not guilty!
I'm sorry.
I don't know why that went off.
Anyway, just an interesting science fact.
Huh, interesting, huh?
Okay, let's go through this one last puzzle and then...
Oh my gosh, what is going on here?
Everything feels like it's taking on like a bit of a life of
its own, you know?
What?
Companion cube!
Oh.
Did I accidentally fizzle that before you could complete the
test?
I'm sorry.
Go ahead and grab another one.
She's a mine.
Oh, no.
I fizzled that one too.
Oh, well.
We have warehouses full of the things.
Absolutely worthless.
I'm happy to get rid of them.
How dare you!
You can insult me.
You can call me garbage thrice.
Oh.
However many times needed.
But to take my companion cube.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, come back, come back.
Taking my companion cube, destroying my companion cube is
not okay with me.
You will hear from my lawyers.
Let's see.
I'm guessing we need you.
Oh, well, I should do that first.
There we go.
All right.
And then we'll make this a little less scary for us.
Right there.
Okay, easy peasy.
Are you ready, cube?
Wow!
Easy!
Oh, I don't know why I keep doing the wrong color.
I can't read.
I can't...
I can't write.
I can't do math.
I can't look at colors.
Easy peasy.
Every test chamber is equipped with an emancipation grill
and its exit so that test subjects cannot smuggle test
objects.
out of the test area.
This one is broken.
Don't take anything with you.
Well, it looks like the door is broken as well, no?
It is.
Oh, we need it.
We need it for this, though.
What do I do with?
Hold on, let's just try it.
No!
Oh, man.
Oh, my cube.
Oh, my lovely little cube.
Oh, my wonderful companion cube.
I'm not taking you with me because she said so.
I wish I could grab you from here.
Please!
God is a cruel mistress.
I like the music so much.
Cute.
Bye, companion queue.
We will meet again.
We'll meet again.
Don't know where.
Oh, I opened my eyes to see a little person.
Well guys, we'll call it here for the first time.
So thanks for joining me for part one of Portal 2.
We're big brain in our way through these puzzles.
They're easy peasy.
I didn't get hung up on any single one of them at all.
That'd be ridiculous.
Thank you, everybody.
Bye-bye.
See you next time.
Bye-bye-bye-bye.